i don't know if callashaw took it as a
compliment he joins us now on loan from
uh
around the horn in dallas morning news
you do you look like a
thinner kenny rogers we go more with
josh brolin
okay around the horn okay
josh brolin on a rough day well isn't
that every day for josh brolin
i think you guys james you know what a
real rough day
i think you should put a side by side of
that picture i sent you
kenny rogers yes okay and do that on
around the horn and let
reality and everybody now did i insult
you by saying you're a thinner looking
kenny rogers was a handsome guy i'll
take a thinner look at anything
you can pick uh are the cowboys easier
to write about when they win or when
they lose
uh they're easy to write about when they
lose uh when they win
uh people feel good you sell more
newspapers when they win
that's a proven thing uh so
so there's that but man
you know now some teams when they're bad
they're just not interesting
and they just kind of go away uh
like i don't know what it's like to
write about when the detroit lions are
bad
they probably just people are waiting
for the red wings to drop the puck
but when the cowboys are bad there's
usually nine different things that are
wrong
and uh this year there there might be
that might be multiplied
so there's you can just pick out of a
hat
and and go from there what does jerry
jones do now you know one of the
real disappointments not one of the
serious disappointments obviously
of coven but one of the real lighter
disappointments
of this year is that he doesn't do press
conferences after every game
because i can't imagine what level he
would have reached
yesterday um you know it's it's
it's one thing to get beat up by seattle
or arizona's offense
they can't stop the run with anybody
not the washington football team they
run for over 200 yards
and if you want to pick one area of the
cowboys that is not beat up by injuries
they're front seven they've got jalen
smith they've got vander rash they've
got demarcus lawrence they've got poe
they've got aldon smith
they got everson griffin they got tyrone
crawford they got guys who are supposed
to be there
and they can't tackle anybody and then
you have the hit on andy dalton
and that nobody seems too concerned
yeah about the cheap shot by uh john
bostick that was it
it took the announcers a minute to kind
of recognize but they did eventually
sell okay that's that's a brutal
hit uh but yeah mari cooper
is standing there and there's others
around
there had to be a number of players see
it i would think the entire offensive
line had to see it
uh and nothing nothing at all i mean i
can't imagine
if that was dak getting hit like that
that they wouldn't have done something
but
that that just pointed to the the give
up factor of this team
they look like in the first quarter
they're out there to see when it's going
to go badly and and
and you know how much it's going to feel
like uh
groundhog day they they got nothing on
either side of the ball
but quitting is worse than losing tim
yeah and and the other of course coaches
will always and players will fight you
we didn't quit
everybody has a great attitude but when
you see something like that
and when you see it that and when you
see a team that just gets
gashed in the run and and announcers
every week whether it's the money night
crew
or yesterday was was moose
or a lot of times it's troy and joe buck
and they get very quickly
fully out of position on these plays
they really get out flanked quickly
with that defense i mean they're they're
talking around the fact the team looks
very poorly prepared and has no idea
what to do and the players
never respond if jerry had a do-over
what would he do other coaching yeah
yeah well that i mean that's what what
was it about
mike mccarthy flying in and spending one
night at the jones house
and oh they were just so wowed by this
guy they couldn't believe it
now what have you seen in any game that
he brings he doesn't call the plays
so anytime the offense was playing well
early in the year
that's kellen moore's offense so what is
he doing over there that he brings i
mean he brought in all these coaches
guys he had in green bay 10 years ago
mike nolan who hired him
20 years ago it's just these this
cronyism type coaching staff and
and you wonder and you wonder how much
uh jerry thought about like a matt rule
he mentioned matt rule one time last
december uh just
after baylor played in the big 12
championship game what a great young
coach
he thought matt rule was and here matt
rule took over a team that was
just god awful and got rid of cam newton
and i mean
they're at least whatever they are three
and four and they compete
uh yeah i mean i i i don't know
i don't know that he wouldn't like to
rethink this a lot now it's the first
year
so i think both the pandemic the back
injury the offensive line being
completely wiped out
those are going to allow the coaches to
skate for a year but he has to be
thinking this
this may have been a terrible hire
are the cowboys buyers or sellers at the
trade deadline
i you know the i don't think they have a
lot to sell i heard somebody saying
trade one of their wide receivers they
don't need that many good ones i mean
that's the one thing they have is good
wide receivers you want to trade one of
those and go
you know draft a a linebacker with a
neck injury that's
that's what excites you about rebuilding
the team i
i i don't think they will do much
they're certainly not buyers
they can't buy i mean i i don't know why
in the world you would add
to a to a terrible collection of talent
that has this many injuries
but i i don't expect them to do a lot
next week
yeah there's nine more games there's a
long season i know
i know but is that good or bad
[Laughter]
it's about for us or for the doubles
here's something
here's something to watch for because
people have talked about
initially oh it's unfair the cowboys are
going to get to have 25 000 fans
and nobody else is having fans and now
some teams are getting some fans
watch in two weeks when the steelers are
here
and see how many terrible towels and
black and gold fans there are in that
stadium
it will be filled with them because the
cowboy fans that have bought those seats
they will gladly relinquish them and the
steelers when they came here eight years
ago
they had 40 000 they will
they travel they travel well yeah they
travel well
what are you going to do with the
quarterbacking position
well i mean that's that's kind of
enormous if i you know you would hope
that's a one week concussion but i
but i have no idea that's something now
if if they thought dalton was going to
be out a long time that's something they
might
have to at least go pick up i don't know
that ben denucci
is ready behind a makeshift offensive
line
that's almost completely unfair so you
just kind of hope
dalton who wasn't playing well by any
means but
he would at least give you a chance in
some of these games against the east
although that wasn't the case yesterday
now that i think about it you wouldn't
think about bringing in ryan fitzpatrick
um if if miami wants to just give you
give him away for a sixth round pick or
something
i i would i wouldn't trade a meaningful
pick yeah they won't but yeah i mean he
would he would he would at least give
you a chance to kind of
deal with the giants and the things in
this division
are you on around the horn uh today dan
today is my fourth episode in a row and
tomorrow is scheduled to be the fifth
this is a
a mariotti-like run that i have not made
in years
you're you're the cal ripken you're the
iron man of around the horn
closing in on the 500th win and we
haven't 485 i believe is the number
so we're looking at mid spring for some
sort of celebration if you want to
yeah but you're your celebrations aren't
as fun
as they used to be so i'm probably not
because it's it's just not there's
you're not fun anymore
well that's more i'm not fighting
parties like that
but yeah i thought my celebrations on
our little television program we're just
fine until now
you've got me nervous now i think i'm
boring all the time no no no no no
no just just on this show that's it just
not on around the horn never no no
you're you're great on around the horn
well i wish you luck and
thank you although i do think that i
didn't even get a response when i said
it looks like you're
uh wearing a bowling shirt uh oh well i
was taking a lot of heat that day
you deserved it i just kind of went with
a casual look
that was our first uh first day back in
this that was the first day i had to do
it by myself
the the the producer has coven so
uh uh i had to do the lights i had to
turn the lights on
i had to put the little card in front of
the camera
white balance so you spent all your time
on setting up the shot and not how you
look
just exhausted i'm sure you were
you're incredible you really are
incredible uh
well it's great to talk to you and uh
i'll be watching as always rooting
i'll be rooting all right and thanks and
thanks again
tim for uh spending some time with my
audience i'm here for you all right
that's tim callashaw dallas morning news